encuentra la probabilidad de tirar
dobles con dos dados de seis caras
numeradas del 1 al 6 así que estos son
dados usuales y lo que queremos saber es
la probabilidad de tirar dobles que
significa tirar dobles pues por ejemplo
si tiro un 1 y en un dado y en el otro
lado también tiene un 1
esos son dobles o si tiro en 12 entonces
en el otro también tendría que tirar 2
cuando se repite el número a eso se le
llama dobles así que 3 con 3 4 con 4
5.566 y bueno para ello voy a pensar
antes que nada en el espacio muestral el
espacio de todas las posibilidades o
resultados posibles de los dos tiros
así que por aquí voy a poner lo que
puede pasar con el dado
número uno dado número uno
y qué puede pasar con él dado número uno
pues puedo tirar un 1 12 13 14 15 y 16
eso es lo que me puede pasar con él dado
número 1 y por acá arriba voy a poner lo
que me puede pasar con él dado número 2
dado número 2 lo que quiero hacer es una
pequeña tabla y que me puede pasar
conectado número 2 pues puedo tirar 1
puedo tirar 2 puedo tirar 3 puedo tirar
4 5 o 6 así que vamos a poner aquí unas
divisiones
otra
y otra
y bueno quizás esa no era necesaria y
ahora estas verticales
ya casi acabó esto es un poco tedioso
pero va a hacer que todo sea más claro
ok
ahí está mi tabla quizás está un poco
fea se nota un poco la mano por acá pero
pero bueno entonces que me dice esta
tabla pues básicamente lo que voy a
hacer es comparar lo que me pasa con el
dado 1 contra lo que me pasa con el dado
2 así que en esta primera columna vamos
perdón en esta primera fila vamos a
poner lo que no pasa con el dado 1 y con
el dado 1 en la primera fila asumo que
saque 1 1
1 y en la segunda fila voy a asumir que
saque 22 22 22 en la tercera 333
3 en la cuarta 444 44 44 en la quinta
555 55 55
y en la sexta 6
666 bien ahora para cada uno de estos
números me puede salir cualquiera de los
demás números en el dado número 2 así
que ahora vamos a ir por columnas en la
primera columna el dado 2 obtuvo un tiro
de 1 así que 1 1
1 en la segunda obtuvo un tiro de 2 2 2
2 en la tercera un tiro de 33 33
3 en la cuarta 44 44 44
en la quinta 555 55 55 y finalmente en
la sexta 66
bien y noten que aquí están
representadas todas las posibilidades
por ejemplo esta casilla representa el
hecho de que saque 3 en el primer dado y
1 en el segundo esta casilla que saque 3
en el primero y 4 en el segundo está que
los dos saque 6 está que en el primer
ataque 2 y en el segundo 6 etcétera y
bueno de todos estos eventos de todos
estos 36 eventos que hay en esta tabla y
6 por 6 cuales representan sacar dobles
pues si saco 1 en el primero tengo que
sacar 1 en el segundo así que este de
aquí es un evento de dobles si saco 2 en
el primero tengo que sacar 2 en el
segundo 3 en el primero 3 en el segundo
4 en el primero 4 en el segundo 5 en el
primero 5 en el segundo y finalmente 6
en el primero y 6 en el segundo así que
estos elementos que están aquí sobre la
diagonal son precisamente aquellos en
los que sacó dobles ahora sí cuál es la
probabilidad de sacar dobles
la probabilidad
dobles
cuál es esta probabilidad pues es el
número de eventos favorables dividido
entre el número de eventos posibles
cuántos son mis eventos favorables son
precisamente estos tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6
tengo 6 eventos favorables y lo voy a
dividir entre el número de eventos
posibles cuántos eventos posibles tengo
pues tengo 36 casillas en este cuadrado
y representan todas las posibilidades
así que tengo 6 eventos favorables entre
36 eventos posibles por lo tanto esto es
lo mismo que 1
sexto de modo que la probabilidad de
tirar dobles con dos dados de seis caras
numeradas del 1 al 6 es de un sexto
tengo seis eventos favorables entre 36
eventos posibles 6 entre 36 es un sexto